turning to my right i see an in-studio
guest from fox sports and the athletic
uh one of the top uh in his profession
covering college sports good to see you
here in person bruce feldman how are you
good to see you in person rich thank you
thank you for coming in here so uh
lincoln riley is here in southern
california
today we saw him coming off the plane in
the beautiful golden light of
southern california wearing the sc shirt
it's so jarring to me and i have no
emotional ties to oklahoma whatsoever
how in the world did this happen this is
a crazy whirlwind rich because it's not
just a usc oklahoma thing remember for
about two weeks there were a lot of
people speculating and some some reports
about how lincoln riley was going to be
announced as a new head coach at lsu
right scott woodward the a.d there he's
the big
splashy hire guy and everybody thought
he was going to get a ridiculous amount
of money and what i was reporting was
he's not going to go there and i had
honestly thought after hearing that the
only place lincoln riley would would
leave ou for was the nfl
at some point that may happen
uh yesterday morning sunday morning i
get a call around nine o'clock our time
11 a.m
uh oklahoma time lincoln riley looks
like he wants to take the usc job and i
was like wait a minute seriously that
like that didn't add up to me for a
while and i kept thinking
then i got a call like i put something
out on social media about it and i just
was like all right this is gonna sound
crazy
and because to me it kind of did because
i was like this is usc they always seem
to bumble their way into things and
screw stuff up they won't not be able to
hire lincoln riley away from oklahoma
then an hour later i got a call saying
yeah he's meeting with the president of
you and this is going down it just blew
my mind because it you know it was
supposed to be lsu that was going to
make the splashy higher right not usc or
credit to usc they pulled off a huge
coup and when you if you ever think
about it usc never even when they hired
pete carroll that was like their fifth
choice it worked out great yes it did
but this is huge for not just usc it's
huge for the pac-12 as well so before we
get to that let's linger on the oklahoma
part of it because you know i was
talking in the the last hour bruce
that um
when oklahoma and texas left
or announced they were going to leave
for the sec we were all just
praising how it was on the uh
before the curve they were they're ahead
of their times and
and oklahoma being in the sec now is
just going to be a boon and
um
why
doesn't
oklahoma uh serve as an attractive spot
for lincoln riley anymore it's not like
the recruits aren't coming all the
top-notch recruits that he had have just
become the decommit and sending out the
googly eyes about you know hey maybe
i'll follow coach somewhere now so
why did things fall apart with lincoln
riley in oklahoma like from what i've
been told a big part of the appeal was
he can come out here and you can
dominate this league right usc we all
know the great history it has i mean has
the heisman quarterbacks it has marcus
and ronnie lot and anthony munoz and
you've gone on the list willie mcginnis
your guy
it's loaded but i think unlike the other
you know and
whether you look at the blue blood
programs alabama ohio state whoever they
all have like a counter right alabama
great program obviously what nick
saban's done there but there's auburn a
m
lsu georgia there's a lot of competing
for that
ohio state they got michigan they got
penn state it's like you're not you're
on relatively equal footing usc there is
no equal footing out here right you are
better positioned you're in a very
fertile recruiting base which as you
mentioned most of those 2023 class which
lincoln riley had committed at ou the
top guys are all southern california
guys so he is recruited out here
extremely well so he knows the landscape
he also knows that the way this
conference is set up being the pac-12
you got oregon's recruiting well with
mario cristobal chip kelly's getting a
little bit of momentum now that they're
eight and four at ucla right but the
rest of the league look at it i mean you
got arizona colorado major rebuild cal
washington now major rebuild i mean
these are real problems and i think
lincoln riley goes i can dominate that
league and i think that in the appeal
with
the chance to rebuild a storied brand as
usc i think that was all very enticing
so
oklahoma joining the fcc
when it's all said and done
got the wheel spinning in lincoln riley
said about getting out i mean is that
the way we can actually connect these
dots because
again it's not a facilities issue it's
not a name issue it's not a brand issue
it's not like they're not going to get
on tv issue i mean normally those are
the top issues for any coach to say i
got to get out of here it's not a
recruiting issue it's not like you can't
get the top recruits issue it's not a
money issue he told the dallas cowboys
no basically to stay where he is
i you know it's kind of the only thing
left is like yeah i don't want to
compete in the sec it's easier to
compete out here so want to go and move
my family to is there a family tie to
southern california not to my knowledge
because i know he and his wife their
their small town texas people you know
and he they have two young daughters so
the idea of moving making a big move and
it is a big move of course it is um is
not insignificant right so i think that
when you look at this by the way he's
almost making eight million dollars a
year the cost of living you and i both
live out here compared to norman
oklahoma i'm guessing i'm guessing
because the usc is a private school he
probably is cracking double digits in
the millions i'm sure the people whose
jack mike tomlin said wasn't large
enough is definitely large enough for
for lincoln riley but again i'm just
trying to hone down that essentially
from what i'm hearing
that the move
that we were lauding oklahoma and texas
for taking because it was a head of a
curve
to go to the sec essentially is
something that lincoln riley
decided was not his bag
and his bag was better out here yeah
we'll see lincoln riley's going to meet
with the media later today we're going
to go over there at i think three
o'clock we'll see how he kind of
explains it but i think again part of
the appeal of why a lot of coaches have
felt like even in spite of cost of
living and some questionable
you know
issues around the program and it's not
like usc is very good right now either
this is a legit rebuild right so
i think the big appeal though is it is
positioned so much ahead of almost
everything else in its conference so to
flip it the way you are i don't think
that would be wrong bruce feldman here
on the rich eisen show
so we had a caller call in from oklahoma
and he basically was talking like the
sky was falling recruits are leaving you
know bob stoops is here i mean there's
an article on the athletic today by one
of your colleagues talking about players
not even knowing if they're practicing
this week or what's going on
and that he's you know this fan was
afraid that this is the end of the
oklahoma run or brand and i'm you know i
try to counsel him against the sky
fallen but what is your boots on the
ground sense of what is happening in
oklahoma today and the the steps forward
i think the part that's probably
troubling especially for uh for fans
like that
is in this day and age because of the
transfer portal
it guys can leave without penalty and
that's i'm not saying that's a bad thing
but it's like you have caleb williams
who's a
budding star at quarterback
you know we know spencer rattler is
already in the portal we expected him
that's not surprising but
does caleb williams eventually decide he
wants to come continue playing for
for
lincoln riley at usc he spent a bunch of
time out here as in his quarterback
development stuff so it's like do some
of those guys decide hey we want to go
there too we expect a big portion of the
oklahoma
staff to also join him at usc so i can
see why it's really concerning
for
fans who are looking like where do we go
from here because as you look and i did
a story on this this morning for the
athletic on who are they going to get
you know matt campbell's a really really
good coach at iowa state he's a
three-time big 12 coach of the year he's
beaten lincoln riley twice and almost
beat him a third time wearing norman i
think they lost by one point he's really
good he was the guy usc was really
looking hard at before lincoln riley
jumped at this offer so
does oklahoma say hey we'd love to have
matt campbell we feel like he he'd be a
great fit here i think that would play
probably pretty well after you get past
that it was like
you know barry switzer is obviously the
godfather of oklahoma football i know he
really likes mike leach a former
assistant to bob stoops doesn't do they
try to bring leach back do they try to
hire lane
the other thing is the a.d there who's a
really good a.d he's made two major
football hires lincoln riley's won bob
stoops the other what do they both have
in common offense guy defense guy they
were both not head coaches maybe they
try to hire there's some good defensive
coordinators out there maybe they make
them be a first time head coach so i
wouldn't rule like completely think
oklahoma football has been really good
for a you know through a bunch of
coaches i think it'll still be really
good as you said they have a lot of
resources but this is definitely a big
pause for them right now well i mean go
ahead you asked that question because
there's the southwest uh there there's
the uh the swac coach of the year what
about dion
what do you think
you know what you're right he is the
swac i mean look credit to him he has
done it he's done a very good job
and he's you know he's out there he's
out there with his toe up in the air you
know i don't know if if
if he's the fit that they want
necessarily i don't know that he isn't
right you know like i don't know if he
wants if he'd want to do that i don't
know if he'd want to do it i mean does
he sit and wait and and look and see
what the landscape is i mean i don't
know he's he is definitely a wild card
coaching hire um
i don't know i mean i'll say this
and i work with some nfl network guy
former nfl network guys and obviously
you are one um
dion as a head coach
doesn't seem as far-fetched for a
college big college job as it did two
months ago
that's all well and i'll say this too um
i i i don't understand what the what the
issue is against you know hiring him
other than the fact that he hasn't done
it before i mean the guys
or a lot i i mean
look he's he's not a guy
honestly florida state should have
jumped at the chance to get him when
they did and i understand that there's
always these people like well he hasn't
had this he hasn't had that he he knows
football and he knows how to talk to
kids and he knows how to be passionate
about it and he knows how to drive
passion as well and and he knows how to
coach i think the challenge with that
and i think this is the challenge with
with with nfl guys i'm not saying that
this is necessarily dion right but like
i think one of the things is
there's a lot of guys who were like i
don't want to recruit like that meaning
it's recruiting it's in the nfl there is
coaches doing i'm not saying they don't
work hard they don't work 365 days a
year to have to deal with recruiting
right and so i think the question was
going to be
how committed is are you going to be to
being all in for all consuming stuff
right it's not to say he doesn't know
football it's certainly not say he
doesn't have connections or any of those
things it's just recruiting is a beast
in college football in terms of that
look he's he's done a really good job
there he deserves credit for that bruce
feldman here on the rich eisen show from
fox sports and the athletic so tell me
what uh what are people saying in the uh
coaching or
evaluation or any community whatsoever
about the michigan win over ohio state
what's the i knew we were gonna get to
this at some point what's the sense in
the 48 hours since the uh the michigan w
there's a lot of people who have had to
eat crow because they had written off
jim harbaugh they either forgot what he
did at stanford and the niners or they
just thought he had kind of lost his way
right and i think he deserves credit for
this first and foremost he reshuffled
his staff josh gaddis really young
offensive coordinator has done a really
good job mike mcdonald who almost nobody
heard of before when he was on john's
staff as an assistant with the ravens
has been a fantastic addition right and
so those are young guys who have played
well i think
the thing that
impressed me the most was watching the
game they you know we have charles
woodson on our on our show at fox
talking about like i think people felt
like this needed to be villanova against
georgetown because oh ohio state's
offense is unbeatable and everything and
it didn't need to be villanova
georgetown where they had to play a
perfect game right we saw mcnamara throw
the pick i'm sure you were wincing on
your couch when you saw that got
momentum it goes away and the reality
was they were the more physical team
this felt in a lot of ways like what jim
harbaugh did to people when he was at
stanford he ran it down their throats i
thought gaddis did a really good job he
implemented a bunch of stuff that that
his buddy joe moorehead the car the
office coordinator at oregon did when
they whipped ohio state in columbus in
september they exploited a lot of issues
on
the on the defensive side of the ball
where quite honestly ohio state is very
shaky the other thing that i think was
you know really impressive not just
aiden hutchinson but both defensive ends
really got after
yeah and uh jabba by the way i don't
understand anybody talked about it but
he he did the lebron with the solid
thing you know and we also know the team
that lebron roots for it was really
fantastic everything from beginning to
end and and and
you're right i thought they did have to
play a perfect game to beat ohio state
every mistake that was being made i
turned to my kids and i'm like that's
exactly the thing michigan can't do they
can't interfere with somebody with a
fair catch they can't let this third and
20 be converted they can't every single
time that that did happen and they took
the blow they were the one to punch back
the third quarter the halftime
adjustments that was michigan's time to
shine and they did it and this whole
series lately has been well ryan day's
got something cooked up and michigan
can't adjust because they only know one
way to do it that wasn't the case this
time around and then by the fourth
quarter hassan haskins was literally
setting up shop in columbus ohio and
saying who's on who wants some of this
business i loved it man i loved every
second yeah i'm sure like this was this
was a vintage harbaugh game and i think
it was a reminder hey right michigan has
the best defensive player in the game by
the way aidan hutchins that hadn't
that's not been that case in a long time
right what i thought was very cool and i
remember seeing this josh ross who's a
linebacker there's a good player and you
have guys obviously aiden hutchinson
legacy guy his dad both parents went
there i was at the school i mean okay so
you know but talking to josh ross in the
summer you could feel the passion and
almost the embarrassment of how it
looked last year and i think what you
had was some real leaders inside the
locker room who deserve a lot of credit
for how they
responded and what it means to them and
i thought that was really cool just i i
would have loved to like the stuff i
talked to josh ross about in the summer
really kind of came back to me seeing
how they played and i thought that was a
really you know it's a really cool thing
for the big ten to see how michigan i
don't say michigan is going to win a
national title i mean they can't afford
to stub their toe this weekend that's
correct you know come down but i just
thought um a lot of stuff must have come
out of people emotionally this weekend
on that scene and you know just to see i
mean just from watching it from the
studio snowfall you know you saw the
energy of it i mean that was that was a
pretty magical day in ann arbor well i
mean iowa's got some amazing blue pelts
on the wall from years past trying to
you know ruining michigan uh national
title hopes i mean just everyone just
google the name chuck long if you want
so obviously every michigan fan
including myself who is
truly you know high-stepping right now
in a couple of days we'll just have to
take a beat and see what happens this
saturday before i let you go bruce
feldman let's talk about these
these conference championship games this
saturday and how it all is going to play
out uh with some quick hitters right
here alabama
must win to get in right there's no way
they sit down somebody with one loss or
zero law says
alabama
honestly it could be one of those sec
classics on cbs last four and a half
hours we're all tweeting about it four
overtimes and it's been phenomenal and
georgia's giving him you know they're
giving georgia the best game georgia
could ever have and they they lose on
the last second kick or something like
that or anything right i mean right i
don't think so alabama has one really
good win out against ole miss they've
had three
really close calls this week against
auburn lsu and florida none of those
teams are very good okay barely beat
them but the other thing is think about
the scenario you just played out now
tell kirby smart yeah you beat them they
really haven't they don't have much
resume but now you got to beat them
again because it's going to be a
one-four match up i don't see how the
committee will okay do that all right so
uh alabama wins and gets in correct oh
yeah all right and then what happens who
who gets sat if you have then you'd have
georgia would still go you'd have two
one-loss teams from the sec they might
be the one in two seeds at that point uh
i think if michigan wins the big ten
they're going i think they would be the
next spot i think cincinnati i think and
there's some people who disagree with it
i think if cincinnati wins i think
cincinnati is in they would beat a
houston team that's a top 25 team it's a
one loss team they have one of the best
wins by the way in the regular season
they went to south bend they beat notre
dame by 11 points you got to give them
credit for that i think that win is
better than anything else at a one loss
oklahoma state team out of the big 12 if
they win i i they're going to play
baylor baylor's good but i just don't
i don't think the committee would take a
one-loss oklahoma state over an
undefeated cincinnati with cincinnati
having that notre dame win but that
would be the discussion there so then
which which teams do you think are
rooting hardest for iowa
this weekend uh
you know obviously because that would
open up a spot right that way yeah
nobody in there yeah i think baylor and
certainly oklahoma state are going to
root hard to see michigan fall because i
think if two lost baylor
beats oklahoma state
they might have they might have an
argument at least to say hey we should
be ahead of one lost notre dame that's
not a conference champ that's 11 and one
that really doesn't have much you know
it's not their fault but they're the
teams they've beaten have not been very
good virginia tech usc stanford those
teams have been way down this year
um you know purdue that's their best one
so i think it really is it helps the big
12 and measurably
if michigan gets knocked off certainly
helps cincinnati i mean they don't they
don't need them there either i mean i
think
those are the teams that would improve
the most and certainly if you're notre
dame you want to see michigan out of
there even though the way it sets up you
know like it would have been better for
them if wisconsin was in that game
because then if wisconsin beats them you
know notre dame has a convincing win
over wisconsin which now iowa doesn't do
anything so does michigan right they do
so so um
so michigan beats iowa
alabama beats georgia
cincinnati wins
so you that that sets up where georgia
plays cincinnati and michigan plays
alabama right maybe i'd i'd be
interested they're not going to send
alabama taking on georgia again no they
wouldn't i think the question is going
to be who's the one too there i mean if
alabama beats georgia
georgia's resume is not going to look as
great anymore remember like who have
they been they got clemson which is a
10-3 game clemson's not very good this
year right it's not like georgia's gonna
have like you're saying michigan would
be the one seed no i'm not saying that i
think alabama might leap frog to number
one at that point and so michigan will
play georgia
yeah i don't know if you want that
matchup
dude i'm taking any match-up right now
you should you sure you're right you
should let's go i i mean who wants a
piece of this right now uh you could say
georgia would fine that's great
i mean right now uh if they get past
iowa
there's no house that's any money that
you know what i'm saying like when
you're looking over my friends no i'm
just like this is going to be tough for
you guys for her
he's a georgia guy
i don't know i mean honestly bring it
uh
maybe something be careful what you wish
for but any game that's in a national
championship semifinal i'll get drunk
it's new year's eve anyway right you
will god bless you
look i think i'm drinking i'm drinking
the montepulciano will be flowing
regardless i think the thing that would
probably woodson cabernet get it going
even further is the fact that if
alabama beats georgia i think then all
of a sudden it's a little bit like
seeing mike tyson get hit by buster
douglas it's like ooh that defense you
know they're vulnerable or whatever so i
think there is an element of you know it
you know the predator it bleeds now and
i because right now everybody looks at
georgia as like you know talk to an nfl
scout there's like three waves of guys
in the front seven right so that's the
thing the scary thing but again they
haven't played anybody yet and i i just
think that the matchup against the
michigan's run game is so good and the
offensive line is playing really well
it's just man george is going to be
george is a scary team and if you're
going to just try to run the ball
against before i let you go who's the
heisman trophy winner i hate this
question um sorry no i mean yeah it's uh
right no i'm s there's not a right now
if you ask me will anderson who has 29
and a half tfls he's the best player in
alabama even better than bryce young
it's hard to say you know right now if
you ask me who my top four would be it's
this mix of will anderson
i think aiden hutchinson from michigan
deserves to be there i think kenneth
walker the running back from michigan
state deserves to be in there yeah and i
think look if bryce young's going to get
his chance if bryce young beats this is
the quarterback alabama freshman he's
been terrific if he beats georgia i
think bryce young wins the heisman if
not
you know i don't see like you know can
he pick it and matt corral quarterbacks
it at ole miss and pitt have had really
strong years i don't think they're gonna
win it i think they're they have a
chance to get there
it's
i don't know this to me this to me is
the wildest heisman year because i think
you'll get a bunch of people voting for
defensive guys but you may get like four
different guys you know jordan davis at
georgia nicoby dean at georgia they may
split whatever votes a defensive guy is
gonna get
i mean it'll come down to this weekend
and
you know what happens hassan haskins
runs for 230 yards this weekend
right all of a sudden it starts to feel
like what ezekiel elliott did when he
was at ohio state he wasn't even like an
all-conference back but he ran wild in
the post when it mattered yeah yeah when
it mattered we'll see when cardel jones
was dominating too and everybody thought
when people didn't think it was gonna
happen right
oh my gosh the stuff mere fact that
we're having having this conversation so
we're entering the final weekend of of
of play with all due respect to army
navy game obviously that we look forward
to after that
we're where the heisman's up in the air
and the only thing we really know for
sure is george's in the final four yes
that is yeah that's it
how about that
it's fine look it's different this year
every year we have in recent years we've
had clemson they're not in we've had
your arch arch-nemesis ohio state
they're not in yeah i've heard that you
know like so we
may not get alabama in it so it's like
there's a lot of new blood here i think
that's not a bad thing i mean since
you know since you know facts and in
your reporter and you you tell
everything straight uh
ohio state's not in
why what happened
to knock them out uh they got beat by
oregon and then they got beat by
somebody else in the big deal yeah very
good we won't even give me the name you
know you don't need that school up north
of the team up north or whatever the
hell it is i do need it i do need it i
want to hear it and that's so funny just
like you don't know because michigan
whipped them they were the more physical
teams right by the way that's a new drop
on the show very good thank you uh
you're the best bruce feldman thanks for
coming here in person let's have you
i'll have you on later on this month and
then hopefully uh next month or whenever
you're willing to get an easy drive
bruce feldman check it out uh check him
out on the athletic as well as uh on fox
sports hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here